The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today's
our last lecture
on dynamic programming,
the grand finale.
And we have a bunch of fun
examples today on piano,
guitar, Tetris and
Super Mario Brothers.
What could be better?
We are, again, going to
follow this five-step plan
to dynamic programming, define
sub-problems, guess something
in order to solve a sub-problem,
write a recurrence that
uses that guessing to relate
different sub-problems,
then build your dynamic
programming either
by just implementing as
a recursive algorithm
and memorizing or
building it bottom up.
For the first, you need to check
with the recurrence is acyclic.
For the second, you need an
actual topological order.
These are, of course,
equivalent constraints.
Personally, I like to write
down on topological order
because that proves to
me that it is acyclic,
if I think about it.
But either way is fine.
Then we get that the
total running time
is number of sub-problems
times time per sub-problems,
and then we need to solve
our original problem.
Usually it's just one
of the sub-problems,
but sometimes we have to
look at a few of them.
So that's what
we're going to do.
And we have one
new concept today
that all these examples
will illustrate,
which is a kind of
second kind of guessing.
We've talked about
guessing in part two
here in which we saw
the obvious thing.
In the recurrence, we
usually take the min
of a bunch of options or the
max of a bunch of options.
And those options correspond
to a guessed feature.
We don't know whether
the go left or go right,
so we try them both.
That's guessing.
But there's another
way to guess.
So two kinds of guessing.
So you can do it in step two.
Let's see what I have
to say about these.
In step two and three,
you are guessing usually
which sub-problems
to use in order
to solve your
bigger sub-problem.
So that's what we've seen
many, many times by now.
Every DP that we've covered
except for Fibonacci numbers
has used this kind of guessing.
And it's sort of the most
common, I guess you might say.
But there's a higher
level of guessing
that you can use, which
we've sort of seen
in the knapsack dynamic
programming, dynamic program,
which is when you define your
sub-problems, you can add more.
Add more sub-problems to
guess or you can think of it
as remembering more
features of the solution.
And we just leave it at that.
Essentially what this does--
so remember with knapsack,
we had a sequence of items.
They had values and sizes.
And we had some target
knapsack, some capacity.
We wanted to pack those
items into that knapsack.
And the obvious sub-problems
were suffixes of the items.
Because we always know
suffixes, prefixes, substrings,
those are the obvious
things to try.
But suffixes wasn't
quite enough.
Because if we
looked at a suffix,
we didn't know of
the prefix that we've
skipped over how
many of those items
were in-- and in particular,
how much of the capacity
we'd used up.
And so we needed to
add more sub-problems
to remember how much capacity
had we used up in the prefix.
We did that by multiplying
every sub-problem
by s different choices, which is
how many units of the knapsack
still remain.
So in some sense,
we're remembering more
about the prefix.
You can also think of it as--
in the more forward direction,
we have the suffix problem.
I'm going to solve
it s different times,
or s plus 1 different times.
I'm going to solve it.
What if I had a big knapsack?
What if I had a
smaller knapsack?
zero-size knapsack?
All of those different
versions of the problem.
In some sense, you were
solving more sub-problems.
You're, in some, sense
finding more solutions
to that sub-problem.
You're looking at a suffix.
And I want to know all these
different solutions that
use different amounts
of the knapsack.
So in that sense, you're just
adding more sub-problems.
But from a guessing
perspective, you're
remembering more about the past.
We're going to see a bunch of
examples of this type today.
We'll always use
this type, but we'll
see more of this where the
obvious sub-problems don't work
and we need to add more.
So the first example is
piano and guitar fingering.
This is a practical problem for
any musicians in the audience.
How many people here play
piano, or have played piano?
OK, about a quarter.
How many people
have played guitar?
A few, all right.
I brought my guitar.
I've been learning
this semester.
I'm not very good yet,
but we'll fool around
with it a little bit.
So the general idea is you're
given some musical piece
that you want to play.
And on a piano, there's
a bunch of keys.
You have all these
keyboards, so you
know what a piano looks
like, more or less.
It's just like a
keyboard, but only row.
It's crazy.
Each key that you
press makes a note,
and every key has
a different note.
So it's very simple from
a computer scientist's
perspective.
You want to play a
note, you push the key.
But you could push it with
any one of these fingers.
Humans have 10 fingers.
Most humans.
I guess a few have more.
But you want to know,
which finger should I
use to play each note?
It may not seem like a big deal.
And if you're only playing
one note, it's not a big deal.
But if you're going to play
a long sequence of notes,
some transitions are
easier than others.
So let's say we're given
a sequence of n notes
we want to play.
And we want to find a
fingering for each note.
So fingering, so let's
say there are-- I'm
going to label the fingers
on your hand, 1 up to f.
For humans, f is
5 or 10, depending
on if you're doing one
hand or two hand stuff.
I think to keep it simple, let's
think about piano, right hand
only, and just you're playing
one note at the time, OK?
We're going to make it
more complicated later.
But let's just think of a
note as being a single note.
OK, or you can think of
guitar, single note, left hand
is playing things.
You want to assign one of
these fingers to each node.
And then you have a
difficulty measure, d.
And this you need to
think about for awhile
musically, or anatomically,
how to define.
If we have some note p
and we're on finger f
and we want to transition
to note q using figure g,
how hard is that?
So this is-- the p and
q are notes to play.
I guess p stands for pitch.
And f and g are fingers.
So this is how hard is it
to transition from f on p
to g on q.
There's a huge
literature on for piano.
There are a lot of
rules like, well,
if p is much smaller than
q, unless they're stretched,
then that becomes hard.
And if you want to
stretch, you probably
need to use fingers that are
far away from each other.
If your playing legato-- so you
have to smoothly go from one
note the other-- you can't use
the same finger on both keys.
So if f equals g and
you're playing legato,
then p better be the
same as q sort of thing.
There's a weak finger rule.
You tend to avoid fingers
four and five, these two.
Apparently going from-- I'm
not much of a pianist-- so
going from between
three and four,
which I can barely hold them
up, it's kind of difficult,
is "annoying."
That's what I wrote down.
So between three and four
transitions you try and avoid.
And so you can encode
into this function.
It's a giant table.
You can just put
in whatever values
you want that you're
most comfortable with.
And music theorists
work a lot on trying
to define these function so.
So you can do that.
And for guitar, maybe I
should do a little example.
Get this out.
I can't play much,
so bear with me.
Bet you didn't think
this would happen in 006.
[LAUGHTER]
So let's see.
So let's say you're trying
to play your favorite song.
[STRUMS "SUPER MARIO BROTHERS"
THEME]
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So when I'm playing that, I have
to think about the fingering.
Which finger is going to
go where to play each note?
OK, so the first notes
are actually open,
so it's really easy.
And then I go up to holding the
first fret on the fifth string.
OK, and I'm using my index
finger because everyone
loves to use their index finger.
And in particular because
the very next note
I'm going to play-- well,
actually it's down here.
Then the next note is
going to be this one.
So I'm holding on the third
fret of the bottom string.
And then I've got to
transition over here.
And actually, usually I do
it with my middle finger.
I don't know quite why I
find that easier, but I do.
OK, and so I've actually
played that opening a zillion
times with lots of
different things.
This is the one I found to
be the most comfortable.
And there's this issue, right?
If your pinky is here, where
can I reach with this finger?
Where can I reach
with this finger?
It gets difficult.
And in particular,
it's very hard for me
to reach down here
when my pink is there.
And so you can encode
that in this d function
however you want.
You get the idea.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
I'll skip to our lessons.
[? We're ?] [? worth ?]
[? it. ?] So let's solve this
with dynamic programming, OK?
That's the cool thing.
So we can do it.
And we follow our
five step procedure.
So the first thing is
to define sub-problems.
What are the sub-problems
for a set-up like this?
What are the three
obvious candidates?
Do you remember last lecture?
How many people know the answer?
Just checking.
One person.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Prefixes,
suffixes, and substrings.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Prefixes, suffixes,
and substrings.
We have a sequence of notes.
We're not going to worry
about the sequence of fingers.
I don't think that's
too big a deal.
That's what we're finding.
What we're given is
a sequence of notes,
so we should try suffixes,
prefixes, or substrings.
I'll just tell you,
suffixes are fine.
Kind of.
So a sub-problem
will be suffixes,
so how to play notes
from i onwards.
Intuitively, we
want to figure out,
how should we play
the first note?
And then we go on to the
second note and so on.
So we're applying
them one by one
from left to right
from the prefix side.
And so we'll always
be left with a suffix.
OK, then we need
to guess something.
What's the obvious
thing to guess,
given I need to
play notes i onward?
Think little harder.
This one you shouldn't
have to think.
That's what I tell you.
Try suffixes, try
prefixes, try substrings.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe which
finger to just put around i?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, which we're
going to use for note i.
Our whole point is
to assign fingering.
The first note here is i.
So let's think about i,
what could you do for i?
We'll try all the possibilities.
Which finger to use for note i?
OK, now the really hard part--
because it's impossible--
is to write a recurrence.
This is wrong, by the way, but
it's the first thing to try.
So this is what
I want to ask you
to do because it's not possible.
But intuitively, what
we might try to do
is we're trying
to solve DP for i.
And we want to find--
this is difficulty,
so you want to
minimize difficulty.
So we'll take a min
over all of our guesses
of what it would take to
solve the rest of the notes,
to play the rest of the
notes, plus somehow the cost
of playing the first note.
So what's the cost of
playing the first note?
And then is going to be
a for loop over fingers.
OK, that's going to be the min.
We want to try all possible
fingers for note i.
Then we have to play
all the remaining notes.
And then there's
this transition cost
where you're going from
note i to i plus 1.
So it's going to
be something like d
of if-- we know that we use
finger f to play i-- then
we have to go to note i plus 1.
But then the problem is we have
no idea what to write here,
because we don't know
what finger we're
going to guess
for note i plus 1.
So this cannot be known.
OK, but it's the
first thing you should
try, because often this works.
For simple DPs, that's
enough for sub-problems.
But we need to know
more information
about what we're
going to do next.
And this seems very
worrisome, maybe
now we have to guess two things.
Do we have to guess
more than two things?
Turns out two things is enough.
But we cannot use
this type of guessing.
We need to use-- we need
to add more sub-problems.
More sub-problem, more power.
So any guesses what we
could do for sub-problem?
A couple of right answers here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe like all
the suffixes [INAUDIBLE]
like the i, for all written i's,
like all the possible fingers
for i?
PROFESSOR: All the
possible fingers
for i in the sub-problem.
Yeah, good.
How to play-- it's still
about the suffixes.
We're still going to use that.
But we're going to
suppose we already
know what finger to use
for the first note, note i.
OK, this is a little weird,
because we were guessing that
before.
Now we're just
supposing someone tells
us, use finger f for that note.
This will work.
That's the one I had in mind.
But the question becomes,
what should we guess?
Anyone else?
You clearly get
[? a pillow. ?] I
don't know how many
you have by now.
Have another one.
That's tough.
This is not easy to figure out.
Now, given that that's
our sub-problem, what
is the next thing to guess?
Do you have an idea?
AUDIENCE: I got an
idea to define it.
Like either the next or
previous finger for the--
PROFESSOR: The next
or previous finger.
Well, I'm looking at suffixes.
So I only care
about the next one.
Yeah.
I see what you mean
by next or previous.
But what we mean
is note i plus 1,
that's the next thing
we don't know about.
So we're going to
guess finger-- we'll
call it g-- for note i plus 1.
And now magically,
this recurrence
becomes easy to write.
So it's almost the same thing.
I wish I could just copy and
paste this over, but I can't.
It's not a digital blackboard.
Are there digital blackboards?
That would be cool.
Someone should make that.
I don't know why switched from
open parens to square brackets,
but I did.
Then we have-- I think it's just
the obvious thing, if i plus 1
g.
Ahh, this is a
slightly wrong, though.
It's a copy paste error.
This should really
be DP of i comma
f, because now sub-problem
consists of two things-- which
suffix am I in, and what's
my finger for note I?
And so when I call DP, I also
have to provide two arguments.
It's going to be DP
of i plus 1 comma g.
And then I'm looping over g.
I'm trying all
possibilities for g.
That's the recurrence.
So if I want starting
with finger f on note i,
how do I solve
the suffix from i?
Well, I guess what
finger am I going
to use for the very next note.
Then I have to pay this
transition cost for f on i
to g on i plus 1.
Yeah, OK.
So slightly, I'm cheating
the notation here.
This probably should be
the note, what is note i,
and this thing should be
what is note i plus 1.
If you think of this d
function just being given
notes, pitches that
you need to play,
instead of indices
into the array.
It doesn't really matter, but
that's how I defined it before.
OK, so I have to pay
this transition cost.
What does it take to make that
transition from i to i plus 1?
And then what does it take to
do the rest of the notes, given
that now my finger is-- or now
finger g is playing the note
i plus 1?
So we transition from
f to g, and that's now
kept track of in
the sub-problem.
This is the magic of
defining more sub-problem.
We needed to know where
our finger used to be.
And now we're telling it,
oh, your finger right now
is finger f.
Finger f is the one that's
currently playing the note.
And then afterwards, g is
the finger that's currently
playing the note, and we
can keep track of that.
You could also define
this to say, oh,
f was the finger that was
used for the previous note,
note i minus 1.
But it's just a shifting
of the indices here.
You can do i minus 1 to i
instead of i to i plus 1.
But this is, I think,
slightly cleaner.
OK, and then we
have a DP, right?
We've just memoized
that recurrence.
We get a recursive DP, or
you could build it bottom up.
If you were building
it bottom up,
you'd want to know
a topological order.
And this requires a
little bit of care
because there's two parameters.
And so it's going
to be a for loop
over those two
parameters in some order.
And I believe the
right order is for i
has to go from right to left
because this is suffixes.
So I would write reversed range
n python if there are n notes.
And then within that loop, I
would do a for loop over f.
If you reverse the order
of these for loops,
it would not be in the right
order, I'm pretty sure.
But this one will work.
You can check it.
And then to solve our
original problem, here
we require a little
more work because none
of these sub-problems
are what we
want to solve because we don't
know what the first finger is.
We know what the first note is.
That's note 0.
But what finger goes there?
I don't know.
And DP of 0 requires
us to give it a finger.
Give it the finger, ha.
Give it the finger for
whatever is the first note.
So this is pretty easy though.
We just take a min
over those choices.
Which finger should we give it?
That should do it.
So we don't know what
finger to start with.
Just try them all, take the min.
This is just like the
guessing that we did here,
just a slightly simpler version.
There's no transition cost
because there's no transition.
We weren't anywhere before.
Just what finger
do you start with?
I don't care what
finger I start with.
It's how I transition from one
note to the next that's hard.
OK, done.
That's the DP.
Now, if this is not
obvious or not clear,
I think it's easier to think
about it in the DAG form.
So let's draw all
the sub problems.
We have here a two dimensional
matrix of sub-problems.
We have the different
suffixes on the one hand.
So this is it, it stats
a 9, goes to n minus 1.
And then in the
other dimension, we
have what finger
to use from 1 to f.
And so in each of these
positions, there a note.
There's a sub-problem.
Race.
I wanted to get five rows
because there are five fingers.
And then our
transitions basically
look-- if we're at
finger one on this note,
we can go to finger
one on the next note.
Or we can go, if
we're not legato,
or we can go to finger
two on the next note,
or finger three or finger
four or finger five.
And then if we're
starting with finger two,
we could go to any one of these.
So you get a complete
bipartite graph,
which you usually
draw like this.
That is how graph theorists
draw complete bipartite graphs.
OK, but I tried to draw a
little more explicitly here.
It's just any
possible transition.
And for each of
these, the point is
you can compute the
D cost, because you
know what figure you were at.
You know what finger
you are going to
and what note
you're starting from
and what note you're going to.
Those are the four
arguments you need for D.
So you put those
weights on, and then
you solve shortest
paths on this DAG.
And that is exactly what
this DP is doing, OK?
Except there's no
single source here,
which is kind of annoying.
And so you need to take
this min over what's
the shortest path from
here, what's the shortest
path from here, from here,
from here, from here.
Of course, you
don't actually need
to do that by running single
source shortest paths f times.
If you're a clever
shortest paths person,
you would add an extra
source note, connect
that with 0 weight to
all of these sources.
So put 0s on there.
And then do single
shortest paths from here.
And you will find the best way.
You don't really care
where you started,
so this is trying
all the options.
That's exactly what
we're doing here.
But here I'm doing it with
the shortest paths trick,
here I'm doing it with guessing
and taking a min like DP style.
OK, so that's how to do
piano figuring and guitar
fingering for single
hand, one note at time.
Questions?
And this even worse
for aliens if you
have arbitrarily many
fingers on your hand.
I guess we should figure
out what's the running time.
So we have sub-problems.
We see how many
sub-problems there are here.
There's n times f sub-problems.
How much time, or how
many choices are there
for our guess?
Well there's f different
choices for what finger we use.
And when we do this min,
we spend theta F time.
Because there's a
for loop over F,
we're doing constant
work assuming
D lookups take constant time.
This is theta F time.
So we multiply those
two things together,
and we get the total time, the
number of sub-problems which
is n times F, and
we multiply them
by theta F for each sub-problem.
So this is nF squared.
And given F is usually pretty
small, it's almost linear time.
So that's a pretty
good algorithm.
But in reality, you tend
to play multiple notes
at the same time.
In music, typically
you're playing a chord.
With piano, you're
playing several notes
with one hand, maybe several
notes with another hand.
Two handed piano, it's crazy.
You could do four handed piano,
make it a little more exciting.
With the guitar, play-- I
don't know very many chords,
but I know at least one.
You play, I don't know.
This looks like something.
That's a G chord.
Do I know any others?
And that's an E chord.
All right, you get the idea.
I mean, for each
of these chords,
different people use
different fingers,
even for a single cord.
So it's sort of a
personal taste how
you're going to define
your difficulty measure.
But I could play an E like
this, or I could-- I don't know,
play it like this.
Or I could play like this.
And there's lots of crazy
ways to put your finger here
and your finger here
and your finger here.
And for each of them, you
could define some difficulty.
And then, of course,
is a transition
from one chord to another.
And because there's different
ways to play different chords,
that wasn't a very good
example because they all
look pretty bad.
Well, this one for example,
this is the G again.
I could use my-- one, two,
three, four-- fourth finger
here, or I could
use my fifth finger.
My instructor says we should
use our pinky because people
tend not to use their pinky.
But it makes a
difference what I'm
going to transition to next.
Maybe my pinky really
needs to go over here next
and I should free
it up for later,
or maybe it's better if this
one's freed because then I
can move it somewhere else.
So that's what we'd
like to capture
in a generalized form
or this dynamic program,
and we can do it.
So I'll try to do
it quickly so we
can get on to the
other examples.
All right, other fun stuff.
Actually, there's
another fun thing
with guitar, which
is that there's
more than one way
to play each note.
There are six strings here.
And you could play like this
note for the Super Mario
Brothers.
I could also play that
doing the fifth thing here.
It's slightly out of tune, but
those sound almost the same.
Or I could play on the 10th
fret on the third string.
That's the same as bottom one.
So a lot of options, so you
also like to capture that.
This is actually not too hard.
You just need to generalize
the notion of finger
to what finger you're using
and what string you're using.
So there are f different choices
for what finger you're using.
If you use a generalized
guitar, there's
s choices for what
string you're playing.
There's a lot of different
guitars with various numbers
of strings, so we can
just generalize that.
And now it's not only, which
finger am I going to use,
but what sting
will I play it on?
And then you can still
define a difficulty measure
like this for this
set up, depending
both on the finger
and the string.
And then the running
time grows slightly.
It's now n times F
squared S squared,
because now I have to take
the product of F and S. OK,
so that's first thing.
But then if I wanted
to do multiple notes,
well, you can imagine it's
a similar type of deal.
It's going to get harder though.
First thing we need to
generalize is the input.
Before the input was
a sequence of notes.
Now it's going to be a
sequence of multi-notes.
So notes of i is now
going to be, let's say,
a list of notes that all
need to be played at once.
And conveniently, it's probably
going to be, at most, F notes,
because you really can only
play one note with each finger
pretty much.
I guess you could try to
play two notes at once
on a piano with
a finger, but eh.
It sounds difficult.
For a guitar, it's
at most s notes.
You can only play one note
per string, more or less.
So that's our input.
And now we need to adjust
the dynamic program.
And I think I'll tell
you how to do this.
Basically, now you need to know
where all your fingers are.
So you go from one
pose to another pose,
from one chord to another.
Different ways to finger that.
Which fingers are
and which strings
and which frets on the
guitar, which fingers
are on which keys
on the keyboard.
But you just need
to know all that.
And all your fingers
might be doing something,
and you've got to know for
each finger what note is it on,
or is it not being used at all.
So how many different ways to
do such a mapping are there?
I mean, this is just a function.
So it's the number of
targets of the function.
So how many of these are there.
Gosh, well, I guess we said
there are, at most, f notes.
So f plus 1 is the maximum
number of possible things
each finger can do.
And we raise that to the power
of the number of fingers.
That's the possible mappings
of what all of my fingers
could be doing.
It's exponential
in f, not so great.
But if f is 5, it's all right.
And then-- well, then you
just generalize the rest.
I don't think I'll
write it down in detail.
But our sub-problems
now are going
to be-- let me
switch boards here.
How do we play these
multi-notes from i onwards,
given that we're going to
use that pose-- or I called
it the state of all my fingers--
for the first notes of i
is now a whole bunch of notes.
So given I'm now going
to play those notes
with this particular
finger assignment,
how do I play the rest?
And then what we'll guess is
the entire finger assignment
for the next set of
notes, i plus 1--
the next chord, if you will.
And that guessing involves
now F plus 1 to the F time.
And then we just write the
recurrence in the same way.
So we're basically generalizing
here we call the finger,
now it's an entire
pose for your hand.
Instead of F, you might write
H for hand or something.
And so the running
time in this situation
is going to go up to something
like n times F of plus
1 to the F. Did I miss anything?
Probably have to square that.
2F.
Before it was F
squared, now it's
just F plus 1 to the F squared.
So if F is small,
this is all right.
Otherwise, not so great.
This is the best algorithm
I know for chord fingering.
Questions?
Just trying to
make it practical,
solve the real life problem.
I would love, I
think-- I don't know
if this has been
implemented, but someone
should implement this
in some-- I don't know,
score program,
musical score program.
I would love as
learning guitar, it'd
be great for someone to just
tell me how to finger things.
Then I can
retroactively figure out
why using the dynamic program.
All right, let's
move on to Tetris.
All these problems are going
to have the same flavor.
You can solve them
with basically
the same dynamic program.
It's all about figuring out
what should the sub-problems be.
So let me-- does anyone
here not know Tetris?
OK, good.
No one's willing to admit it.
So you've got these
blocks falling.
But I'm going to make several
artificial constraints.
First of all, I tell
you the entire sequence
of pieces that
are going to come.
This is more like
a Tetris puzzle.
OK, we're given sequence
of n pieces that will fall.
For each of them, we must
drop the piece from the top.
OK, and if you're a
fancy Tetris player,
you can let a piece fall and
then rotate it at very end
to do some clever, clever thing.
I disallow that.
You always have to
push the drop button.
So the piece starts here, it
goes instantly to the ground.
This will be necessary.
I don't know how to
solve the problem
without this constraint.
OK, and then the
other weird thing--
this is very weird for Tetris--
full rows normally clear,
but now they don't clear.
This is like hardcore Tetris.
You're guaranteed
to die eventually.
The question is, can you
survive these n pieces?
That's the question.
Can you survive?
Oh, I've got one
other constraint.
This is actually
kind of natural.
The width of the board is
small, relatively small,
because we're going to
be exponential in w.
In real life it's 12, I think?
AUDIENCE: Ten.
PROFESSOR: Ten, sorry.
It's been a while since
I wrote my Tetris paper.
So all right, these are all
kind of weird constraints.
If you don't make all of
these constraints-- oh,
also the board is
initially empty.
That's like level one of Tetris.
If all of these things
are not the case, which
is regular Tetris, if you
just have the first thing
then this problem is
called NP-complete.
We'll be defining
that next class.
So it's computationally
intractable.
But if you make all
of these assumptions,
the problem becomes
easy, and you
can do it by
dynamic programming.
So how do we do it?
We define sub-problems
just like before.
The obvious thing
to try is suffixes.
How do we play a suffix
of pieces i onwards?
How to play those guys.
And just like fingering, this is
not enough information, right?
Because if we're going to play
from pieces i onward, what
we need to now is what the
board currently looks like.
I said here the board
is initially empty.
That's not going to
be the case after you
place the very first piece.
So in general, after we've
placed the first i pieces,
we need to know what
the board looks like.
And here's where I'm going to
use all of these assumptions.
If you always drop things from
the top and rows don't clear,
then all you really care about
is how high each column is.
This is what you might call
the skyline of the board.
OK, now in reality,
there might be holes here
because you drop
things in silly ways.
Maybe you drop a
piece like this.
And then I claim, because
I'm dropping things
from infinity from
the sky, I really
don't care about that
there's a whole here.
I can just fill that in and
say, OK, that's my new skyline.
Because if you can't do
these last minute twists
and if lines never clear,
that's going to be gone.
That material is wasted.
OK, so all I need to remember
is how high is each column.
So I should say given
the board skyline.
Now, how many choices
are there for that?
It's quite similar to this
function, the fingering.
Let's see.
There's the height of the
board, different choices.
It's going to be h.
For each column it could be
anywhere between 0 and h,
so I guess h plus 1 if
you want to get technical.
And then we raise
it to the power w,
because there's w different
columns and each of them
is independent choice.
So this is going to n times
that different sub-problems.
And here's what I
need the is small
because this is
exponential in w.
So it's reasonable in
h, but exponential in w.
OK, then what do I guess?
Any suggestions what to guess?
AUDIENCE: So where the new
piece falls, as in [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What should I do with piece i?
There's not that many choices.
I can rotate it zero,
one, two, or three times.
I can choose
someplace to drop it,
but those are my only choices.
So it's just how
to play piece i.
And given that guess,
you can figure out
how the skyline updates,
like I did here.
If I drop that piece like
that, then I fill in this part
and recompute my new skyline.
So it's going to
be something like 4
times w different choices,
roughly-- 4 for the rotation,
w for the x-coordinate.
And so the running
time is just going
to be the product of these.
n times w times h
plus 1 to the w.
Open problem, if I drop any
one of these assumptions,
can you get a dynamic
program that's reasonable?
Could you do it if w is large?
I don't know.
Could you do if rows do clear?
That's the least
natural constraint here.
I don't know.
Puzzle for you to think about.
I'd love to know the answer.
You can obviously do the
rest of the steps, right?
You can write down
the recurrence.
It's the same thing.
You take the min
over all guesses.
What are we minimizing?
Hmm.
I guess here the
question is survival.
Can you survive?
So this is one of the first
examples where the answer is
a Boolean value, true or false.
But if you think of true
or false as 0 and 1,
then it's still a
maximization problem.
You want to maximize.
You want 1 if possible.
Otherwise, you'll get
0 when you maximize.
So you can write the
recurrence using max.
And in the base case, you have
truth values, true or false.
And you'll see, did I survive?
Did I die?
That sort of thing.
I want to go on to
Super Mario Brothers,
because everyone loves
Super Mario Brothers.
has?
Anyone not played NES
Super Mario Brothers 1?
Aww, you got to play it, man.
You're the only one.
You can play it on an emulator.
Maybe not legally, but you
can play it on an emulator
and just see how it is.
So what I'm going
to talk about next,
in theory, works for many
different platform games,
side-scrolling platform games.
But Super Mario Brothers
1 has some nice features.
In particular, a nice feature
is that whenever anything
moves off of the screen, it
disappears from the world.
So the monster moves
off, it's gone.
You can think of there's
a static level there.
When the level comes into
screen, when a monster comes
on screen, then
it starts acting.
But as soon as you move the
screen-- you can't actually
move backwards in Super
Mario 1, but as soon
as you move forwards and
that character is offscreen,
it's gone.
So in a sense, that
part of the level
reset to its initial state.
Now, as long as your screen is
not too big-- and thankfully,
on NES screens
were not very big.
It's 320p, or whatever.
This will work.
If you are given
the entire level--
so let's say there's n
bits of information there--
and you have a small screen,
w by h screen, w and h
are not too big.
Then I claim we can
solve Super Mario
Brothers by dynamic programming.
So let's say we want
to maximize our score.
Want to run through the level
and maximize your score,
or you want to minimize
the amount of time you use.
You're doing level runs.
Pick your favorite measure,
all of those can be solved.
And the way to do it, this
sort of general approach
to all these DPs is
we need to write down
what do I need to know
about the game state.
I'll call that a configuration.
What can we care about
for Super Mario Brothers?
Well, I guess
everything on screen.
This is a bit tricky, but
there's stuff on screen.
There are monsters and objects.
For the monsters, I need to
know their current position.
For the objects, I
need to know-- like,
is there a question mark box?
Did I hit it already?
Did I already get the coin or
did I already get the mushroom?
So for each of those
things, there's
some amount of information
you need to store.
How much information?
I think something like constant
to the w times h should do.
That's saying for every
pixel on the screen
or for every square
on the screen,
however you-- whatever you
define the resolution here
to be.
Let's say for every little
unit square in Mario land,
is it a brick?
Is it a hard brick, or has
it been a destroyed brick?
Is a monster there right now?
Is Mario there right now?
All these kinds of information.
OK, so there's a cost number
of choices for each pixel.
You can write them all down.
You might also want
Mario's velocity.
I had to play it
again just to check
that there is indeed velocity.
Turning around is slower
than going forward.
You do accelerate a little bit.
So you've got to remember that.
There's probably only
a constant number
of choices for what
your velocity is.
What else?
Ah, I want to
remember the score.
You want to maximize score.
And let's say you also--
how much time is left.
There's a time counter.
If it hits zero, you die.
Now, these are kind of annoying,
because they're integers.
They could be kind of large.
So I'm going to say the
score could be capital S big,
and time could be capital T big.
So this'll be a
pseudopolynomial algorithm.
The number of
configurations in total
here is the product
of these things.
It's exponential in w and h.
And then multiply by
S and T. So that's
the number of configurations.
And that's also going
to be our sub-problem.
I guess we should
also write down
where is the screen
relative to the level.
OK, how far to the
right have you gone?
That's another w.
That's not a big deal.
OK, given this information,
you know everything
you need to know about
playing from here on.
And the time counter's
always going to keep ticking.
So you can draw a graph
of all configurations,
just enumerate all
of these things.
It's this many of them.
And then draw, for
every configuration,
what are the possible
things I can do?
I could push this button.
I can push the A button, I
can release the A button.
I can push the B button, I
can release the B button.
I can push the up arrow.
Those are all the
things you could do.
It's a constant
number of choices.
So each vertex will have
constant out degree.
If you did this, what
configuration would I reach?
Just draw that whole graph.
Do shortest paths.
Or dynamic programming,
these are your sub-problems.
There are no suffixes here.
These are your sub-problem.
And then you take
a max, if you're
trying to maximize score or max
if you're trying to maximize
time, minimize the time you use.
This is time remaining.
And you can relate
each sub-problem
to a constant number
of other sub-problems.
So your running
time will be this,
because you only pay constant
time per sub-problem.
And now you can solve Super
Mario Brothers optimally,
as long as your screen is
not too big and as long
as your scores and times
don't get too big either,
because we're only
pseudopolynomial with respect
to S and T.
Questions?
All right.
That's-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So are we
going to be trying
to memoize all of these
possible configurations?
PROFESSOR: If you do
the recursive version,
you will end up memoizing all
of these configuration values.
Well, anyone that's reachable
from the initial state.
Some configurations
might not be reachable,
but the ones that
are reachable you're
going to start doing them.
When you finish doing them,
you will memoize the result.